anyway there's one way to reach out to
this audience about the difficulties of
being a pimp I think it's clearly
through interpretive dance alright
the next award is for sound editing
again there's another category I felt
the lobbying went a little over the line
people are talking about Richard King
sound editing on War of the Worlds
but experts say it's just a lot of white
noise the Boston sound editor time says
Kings lack of cross modulation tests on
his dialogue beds resulted in distortion
and amplitude aliasing often to the
point of asperity noise isn't it time
the best achievement and sound editing
Oscar went to a nominee who truly
manipulates multi-channel audio and a 48
kilohertz sampling rate isn't it time
for a wily statement
I can still hear three 6 mafia's down
there ladies and gentlemen here to
present the award in this always
controversial category Jennifer Garner
thank you I do my own stunts sound
editing is a complex art it in fall it
involves assembling all the auditory
elements involved in a film and
frequently creating and manufacturing
sounds that have never been heard before
this year's nominees had their skills
tested to the max the nominees are Mike
Hopkins and Ethan van der Rhine for King
Kong Wiley statements for Memoirs of a
Geisha Richard King for War of the
Worlds and the Oscar goes to Mike
Hopkins and Ethan van de Rhine for
Qinghai this is the second Academy Award
and second nomination for Mike Hopkins
and Ethan van der Rohe they took home
their first Oscar in this category for
one of the rings that
Towers
we want to thank Peter Jackson and Fran
Walsh for their spectacular vision which
is matched only by their by their
spectacular generosity of spirit and
heart we're so proud to stand here and
accept this award on behalf of our whole
crew who continue to prove that with
unconditional creative collaboration the
impossible becomes possible and in
particular we want to thank the amazing
Brent Burge and the one-of-a-kind Andy
Serkis who brought the voice of Kong to
life and also Erlich to especially thank
Chris Ward Mountain Court pepper
Anderson and the the like amazing people
pack Road and also the God that paved
the raid where I've paved the way for us
Miriam's Vivek the original Sanders
honor for the 1933 version of King Kong
Mary hope um take piece of it thank you
thank you so much